bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono famigie oggi
giocheremo a cat mario allora
piccolissima premessa cat mario è un
videogame che mi avete consigliato in
tantissimi nell'ultima settimana in
questa settimana qui mi saranno arrivate
siano 30 così buttateli più o meno 30
mail nelle quali mi chiedevate di
giocare a cat mario allora in genere io
e videogame prima di giocarli di guardo
c'è guardo gli screen guarda un po come
sono e poi se il videogame mi piace in
generale decido se farlo o no cat mario
così come altri videogame che ho fatto
in passato è uno fa parte di quella
categoria di videogame che no non ho
visto non sono anche come perché me lo
avete consigliato talmente in tanti che
non possono farlo penso dato che è un
gioco che è molto simile a mario si
chiama cat mario appunto è simile a
mario penso che penso che non sia come
uno dei miei soliti video nel quale non
so delirio come un matto pure grido di
paura oppure rido perché ovviamente e
mario è un gioco abbastanza tranquillo
in generale quindi non so che cosa vi
potete aspettare da questo episodio non
lo so neanche io e quindi direi di
iniziare allora press and perche i ok
effetto e ragga siamo partiti sono un
gatto che salta su dei fantasmini che mi
sembrano dei pokémon cosa sta facendo mi
sta trovando st fare
e va beh sembra in tutto e per tutto
uguale a maria sto punto non so che cosa
mi devo aspettare
diventiamo gigante ok sono sono morto
sono morto
sono morto perché sono morto quella fare
in teoria non dovrebbe farti diventare
un gigante o cose del genere no si vede
raga che mi ricordo non ho veramente ma
quando prende vista cosa in super mario
non diventare un gigante enorme tipo
perché non funziona vabbè meno siamo
andati in negativo adesso ci abbiamo
meno una vita perfetto
ok direi di proseguire a questo punto
non la prendo con la fare l'impossibile
mi ricordo male io mi ricordavo che
diventa vi tipo una cosa enorme quando
prende visto a fare ma vabbè c'è un tubo
mi stanno crollando che cazzo mi starà è
un troll sto gioco una cosa assurda
decisamente non uscivano sti cosi dai
tubi però non fa niente ok che cazzo
questo è un trampolino tipo quello di
scribe l'auto cosa
va beh noi facciamo finta di niente
andiamo giù perfetto che cazzo sono
decollato ma che cos'è ma no ma perché
sono morto
ma nei tubi da quando si decolla vabbè
non raga non sto capendo quello che sto
giocando non va beh noi e non andiamo
giù andiamo avanti è perfetto ma che
cazzo ok
bene allora c'è non ho giocato così
tanto a supermario quello originale
perché diciamo sono nato un po dopo
l'uscita di super mario per dire però
sinceramente non me lo ricordavo proprio
così è un trolls c'è una cosa che c'è
una cosa invisibile lì non ho capito c'è
ma che cazzo c'è ma allora pur non ha
senso
guarda che allora porca di quella
[ __ ] come cazzo ci passo qui come
faccio a passare di qua c'è una forse
salto semplicemente che idiota
ok ce l'ho fatta è stata la cosa un po
incasinata ma ce lo fa una donna che
cazzo è caduto e che adesso cadono anche
i cubi da allora barbera che non ha
senso non ha senso non è su non è ma
porca [ __ ] non mi ricordavo che c'era
quello a fare lì
ok allora piano calmissimi dobbiamo
riuscire a superare sto punto perché non
ha senso solo all'inizio
all'inizio si fa in 20 secondi so pezzo
non ha senso allora devo saltare questo
punto ok poi c'è quella fare che cade
c'è un affare
ok perfetto adesso devo saltare
no che non ci arrivo perfetto devo
riuscire a saltare di sopra ok
che culo che curva sono andato
abbastanza lento c'è una bandiera c'è
una bandiera con scritto fa vj perché
l'ho presa ho preso la bandiera con
scritto fa vj fantastico
bene adesso non so che cosa devo farlo
dove cazzo sono fini a ok la bandiera
era un check point
meno male perché avrei lanciato qualcosa
ok allora bene non mi ricordo
sinceramente dov'era il pavimento che
cadeva se si ok era lì perfetto calmi
calmi
devo riuscire ad a proseguire la sto
punto qui fortunatamente la bandiera fa
vj mi ha salvato ho capito forse perché
mi avete consigliato sta roba
maledette roba per farti imprecare per
tutto il video praticamente grazie
ragazzi
però intanto qua c'è un punto
interrogativo che non avevo preso ok la
moneta allora direi di proseguire c'è ok
mi aspettavo una trappola di ogni genere
ma non è successo niente
porca [ __ ] ma non è possibile non è
possibile allora io me le aspetto ste
cose ma non è allora porca [ __ ] c'è
non è possible donna madonna che cazzo
no se si ok allora ce la posso fare
ce la posso fare se sì ok f mi spiegate
il senso di tutto questo voglio capire
perché perché perché madonna mia posso
mai a incentrare il buco minuscolo
allora porca [ __ ]
devo riuscire a saltare perfetto nuvola
del cazzo ok ciao
no no no no
meno 20 ma allora basta mi sta facendo
alterare abbastanza
no sono di obino benedetto no non ce la
posso fare
raga ma questo è un gioco per masochisti
non posso fare c'è ma allora fatemi no
no come si fa a fare sto punto di merda
devo entrare mica nel tubo no perché poi
decollo
porca [ __ ] [ __ ] porca [ __ ] [ __ ]
porca [ __ ] [ __ ] allora piano è fin
qui
ok poi no no ok madonna show l'ansia
calmi allora devo saltare su sta roba
perfetto poi devo andare
devo andare ok perfetto qui solo che in
sto punto qui non ci posso andare quindi
deve entrare nel tubo devo entrare nel
tubo non funziona
ok devo tornare indietro non posso
tornare indietro perfetto devono tentare
di schivarli in qualche modo si è ok
adesso non so come fare però devo
provare a fare tipo ok ce l'ha fatta
ok ragazzi siamo c'è la bandiera finale
devo aspettarmi un qualche tipo di
trabocchetti
lo sapevo che dovevo provare a giocare a
sta roba prima di farci un video lo
sapevo io devo sempre provare prima di
fare i videogames perché se no finisco
così anche se me li consigliate lo
sapevo dovevo aspettarmelo 9 di non ci
riesco più non ci riesco più non ci
riesco più allora venite qua brutti
bastardi perfetto cosa devo fare qui
devo andare giu ok
bene adesso devo passare sta roba che
non so come si passa
ok cellophane no no no no come che cazzo
è successo non stava neanche andando
avanti io c'è ma non ha senso stato
allora cosa devo fare la caccia non ha
più non ho capito
[Musica]
fottetevi tutti ok mi sono calmato
allora cosa devo fare qui devo saltarla
la bandiera cosa non ci riesco a sotto
alla maniera non c è fermo fermo ma
basta raga basta
ok ragazzi siamo cercherò di prendere
una rincorsa che manco usain bolt mi sta
dietro questo è l'ultimo [ __ ]
tentativo che faccio perché è veramente
ne ho abbastanza
cerco di prendere più in corsa possibile
ok ho l'ansia tra mille cazzo ma si può
vabbè 3 2 1